horse assassin ii is known as the aunty
of garbage in this slum in putting and
she's got plenty of work to do her job
is to go from door to door to pick and
salt trash
like most waste pickers Xhosa is from
India's done it
untouchable community who faced
widespread prejudice and marginalization
she started rag-picking
when she was a teenager more than thirty
years ago for a long time
city officials and residents had a
Strasse and she toiled in filthy
unsanitary conditions that changed nine
years ago when Xhosa joined the
co-operative of whist beakers called
swatch it struck a deal with city
authorities to get the rights to
collecting the city's garbage earlier
there was so much discrimination we
couldn't even use public taps to drink
water people used to call us thieves now
there's been a huge change people let us
into their homes to get the garbage some
even offer us a glass of water we
provide a professional service in return
we get respect working conditions have
also improved the co-operative services
about six hundred thousand households
across the city from slums to high rises
municipal authorities provide workers
like Xhosa the protective gear and
health insurance HOSA can use the
elevator now something should remember
we speakers were denied earlier
households in this apartment block is
sixty rupees that's less than a euro
every month for the garbage collection
service fighting for her rights is
something Horsa learned at the
cooperatives along with other waste
pickers she's on the organization's
board many women here including Xhosa
are illiterate but that hasn't stopped
them from making the voices heard
HOSA was even invited to France a few
years ago to speak about ways because
rights because have come together form
the co-operative and their own and they
are the decision makers of this
organization itself means there's a lot
of process of empowerment that's going
on twice a week Xhosa heads to a
neighborhood scrap dealer separating
plastics paper tin and glass she
salvages the recyclables from a daily
garbage while the trash which is further
sole to recycling firms helps boost
horses intim altogether Xhosa takes home
about nine thousand rupees that's around
a hundred and twelve euros every month
it's a significant sum in a totally
informal sector Xhosa also has big
plants alone for the co-operative helped
her build a concrete house for herself
and her family after years of living in
a makeshift tin hut in the same the
two-story building could be ready in a
few months
Xhosa says other waste pickers have been
able to send the children to school and
college thanks to the work in the
co-operative but she says the benefits
aren't just monetary after years of
organizing protests and fighting for our
rights I've learned to overcome fear I'm
self-confident now I've come so far for
now the co-operative has achieved an
unthinkable triumph women from the
lowest caste are pushing for their
rights and cleaning the city with a
sense of dignity and purpose